[Music]
[Applause]
how's it going bros my name is peter bat
welcome to ex more days I'm just kidding
that I wasn't left full of web designs
percents in a very nice blood is clean I
don't even know that been LeFleur was
that been left her baby stop Danna Jesus
crying come on not again
I knew it next Mattias we we yes thanks
Marcus what yeah that's wrong
alright whatever hi again
oh ah you wake up in the woods with a
lump on your head you can't remember how
you got that all your recalls are all
you can recall are the dreams it's late
cause you're unsure whether you are
exactly fighting through the headache
you know again you're focusing you see a
house in a clearing and decide to
shelter where bad decision buddy
anything is better than facing it it I'm
pretty sure I'm pretty sure better
freezing in the woods how cold can it be
honestly like whatever I wouldn't go
there nope then that house has no
printing all over it it's on the nope
streets nope Street all right
what'd I do oh sorry
oh I'm supposed to fix it oh there's not
a lot of work that needs to be done here
let's start with upstairs kind of creepy
whispering but okay oh I need to wash
the windows I need to clean the walls
are these carpets looks disgusting
okay what every time you go upstairs you
die any any time no exception
all right let's meet we got blood the
bed's over an hour's ride all right good
why not where's that there's no breeze
so why is the roof flap swinging it's a
ghost lamp I think I Caramba okay what
is this a gramophone is unplugged but
it's still rotating how's it possible
makes no sense I don't know how is it
possible if it's unplugged
it's got to be a battery or something
yes of course and this has to be like a
one of those spinning things like
whatever these five five one three all
right why the hell is it so much blood
enough it's gonna take forever to clean
you know how difficult that is to clean
blood it's very difficult okay huh that
was fast
I found a key large in power sing all
right get the windows barbed up but
maybe someone who valued their privacy
yeah of course I mean maybe you just
want some privacy while they were
killing people in the back yeah and
in the bathtub that's what it's called
okay fine fine I don't care I don't care
let's go back let's go check bounce
share something second all the way wait
although genius probably sent my
girlfriend a hey whatever all right
okay mmm its face looks nice thought so
he's hung him by the arms that's been
ripped to shreds the wretch at the merit
you wretched the murse why am I still in
this building I don't understand oh I
know I'm gonna do this I can click bad
what's this the [ __ ] is that I have no
idea what that is
can I pick it him in my inventory or
something what is it Oh God
what was it or something else here oh I
liked ahead three four eight nine all
right good good I was in here I
hello three four eight no three four
nine eight three four I'm just kidding
again how did that i/o anything
uh-oh it's a sign it's best to be her
always I thought over the head
Wow this big heart can I touch it
Oh what is this
ex mortis the book of X mortis what was
before the dawn of man and peace the
earth way and was ruled by ancient
mystical beings transcripted life death
time and reality as most were mortal
know it the days before life in light
ruled by darkness and chaos this is
really boring if you like you can read
this you just have to click pause you
bro bro bro
and look very again yeah strange symbol
I I seen that before but is there
nothing else we can click all right fine
okay let's go back and I think there's
something here I don't know
okay well it's nothing I'm okay we
haven't been downstairs yet so we
shouldn't go there I guess okay let's
see what we're gonna find here are you
come back I got to clean so many things
to clean oh oh I hate corridors row row
what uh-oh bro bro no bro
I don't like that bro Oh Oh God
I wasn't ready for that I got me good
I got really freaked the hell out of me
all right no I was probably on a
hallucination happens all the time
cellar entrance all right it's only the
door the handle taos but the door
I remember what handle turns my the door
fuses bad you don't like someone's hope
I don't like when you like bad all right
okay let's just go in here where the
freaking thing was okay what is this
kitchen why is there no woman in here
put on porch
I should have an Oscar for you know
making bad jokes all right what is this
Oh ninjas lifeblood say next week okay
how do I pick things up I can oh thank
you do Oh bro bro bro bro your head bro
oh yeah we will send some too that's a
shame I'm kidding of course I'm kidding
the old dishwasher stupid lady all right
saying something else
i Caramba Iook around is all I gotta say
that's [ __ ] gay all right what have
we got
Stefano you're here Oh God so much
sticks an unusual event filleted I
stumble across an usual find was out
hunting for deer and remote wildness
stalking a white sheet and claiming you
can only madam I surprised to find a
house holding seemingly abandoned but
still staying strong and interesting
fine one that certainly has me curious
if you want to read this you can just
pause and all I can't stop I don't care
sorry it's like 50 pages Jesus Christ I
don't have to ever know all right missus
yeah well you okay it's something I'm
missing
I don't think so a coffee table Brad
where's it blood everywhere it's like
does it really have to be everywhere I
don't like his clock okay what's the
else secrets huh it shows one right I
guess is the key I didn't even know I
had a key but sure okay Oh severed arm
it's turning out to be a graveyard well
look at that huh
it's blinking they stopped blinking I
can see you stop what is this
abcdefg a ji alright interesting yes but
like what do you want to do with the
this game makes no sense
that frickin sign again why am i
stealing this out oh god the tale of the
doctor Gwen is sad and soluble tape tale
tapes what
yes yes very interesting no but there's
like no clues and knees
I wouldn't feel like an idiot all right
what's going on here stop looking at me
stop looking at me
well that's that sign again I don't
trust that sign okay all right that's
pretty much it for today I hope you
enjoyed liking for you if you want you
and I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the [ __ ] brahh